ein anderes foto vom wochenende sehr im
kader die stadien schon angesprochen
können sie erklären warum man in der
loge beim fc bayern münchen eng
beieinander sitzt aber stattdessen ganz
streng in der fankurve die regeln
einhält
nein absolut nicht
und ich muss sagen als ich das bild
gesehen aber er hat freunde was ist denn
mit euch los der deutsche fußball-bund
hat regeln und die damen und herren
halten sich nicht an dieses übermut oder
ist es so eine wir sehen das ja auch auf
von vielen oder von manchen politikern
in eine art ländern also äußern sich
dazu den chor ohne regeln und gehen
abends den privaten mit vielen leuten
feiern
all diese fälle gab es schon gilt dann
manchmal ja für mich muss das nicht
gelten oder ich krieg das ist nicht das
ist jetzt überhaupt mitglied bei
borussia dortmund mit das hat damit gar
nichts zu tun ich würde sagen wenn es
völlig anders wäre aber was ich da
gesehen habe spontan meine mein gedanke
dummheit oder arroganz